du personnel surchargé qui s'occupent
d'un trop grand nombre de patients la
situation est critique affirme 12
groupes qui représente notamment les
infirmières elles ne sont pas en mesure
de donner l'ensemble des soins de fer
l'entièreté de leur travail et sa salle
a des conséquences pour plusieurs
personnes pour améliorer la qualité des
soins prodigués et les conditions de
travail il réclame l'adoption de normes
qui définiront le nombre maximal de
patients dont peuvent s'occuper les
professionnels de la santé on demande au
gouvernement d'instaurer une loi qui va
garantir des ratios dont des équipes de
soins en nombre suffisant pour chacun
des unités de soins chacun des milieux
de soins au québec que ce soit les
hôpitaux les chsct si on veut améliorer
de façon structurantes la pratique
infirmière puis la qualité des soins
dans le réseau de la santé les projets
une loi sur les ratios minimum c'est une
des mesures structurantes le projet dans
ce sens
une demande formulée alors que les
salles d'urgence débordent dans
plusieurs hôpitaux un ratio sécuritaire
dans l'unité de soins de médecine par
exemple va permettre à ce que l'urgence
soit moins débordés parce que les livres
vont être disponibles à ces patients-là
de l'aller dans d'autres unités le
gouvernement couillard avait lancé des
projets pilotes en 2018 pour établir des
ratios patients infirmières
l'un d'entre eux s'est déroulée à
l'hôpital de dole en outaouais à
l'urgence une infirmière s'occuper d'un
maximum de quatre patients actuellement
ce qu'on voit c'est qu'une infirmière
peut avoir dix des x men 15 patients
dans une urgence donc imaginer la charge
de travail que ça peut générer
l'inévitable masala des conséquences ont
mis 2020 les libéraux avaient déposé un
projet de loi pour rétablir des ratios
dans le système de santé mais le
gouvernement legault n'a pas voulu
l'adopter si le gouvernement ne légifère
pas par rapport à ces projets ratio bas
on ne peut pas garantir un accès aux
soins de santé de qualité
on ne peut pas se commettre à des ratios
sur n'est pas le bon nombre de personnel
vous mettre les choses dans l'ordre
c'est une question de négociation de
convention collective et le coma sera en
première les deux groupes qui réclament
une noire et or que l'instauration d'un
ratio pourrait au contraire attirer et
retenir davantage de travailleurs dans
le système de santé il affirme que
l'expérience l'a prouvé en californie et
en australie ici olivier machin radio
canada montréal